Chromosome 10 is
extraordinary.
We all know what it's like if
we're forced out of bed way
before 5 o'clock
in the morning.
It takes us a long
time to wake up.
We all have a day within, a
biological clock, also called
a circadian clock.
And what this does--
and it really can't be
overemphasised--
is regulate almost every aspect
of our physiology and
behaviour, fine tuning
physiology and behaviour to
the varying demands of activity
and rest, cranking up
hormones and metabolism in
anticipation of activity, and
turning it down again in
anticipation of sleep.
So the sleep-wake cycle, changes
in blood pressure,
changes in temperature still
show a near 24 hour
oscillation, but it wouldn't
be exactly 24 hours.
And so what needs to happen
every day is that this
slightly drifting clock needs
to be adjusted to
environmental time.
And the most important signal
that the clock needs is
exposure to the light-dark
cycle.
And that light-dark is detected
in mammals such as
ourselves by light-detecting
cells within the eye.
It's critically important that
the body clock is adjusted
every day by the light-dark
cycle.
If you didn't get that daily
adjustment, then internal time
would be abnormally
synchronised with
the external world.
And perhaps the best example
of that is jet lag.
So we knew that these
photoreceptors were in the
eye, because if you prevented
light getting to the eye, then
the body clock no longer
responded to light.
So there's something
in the eye.
The big problem was that it
was very difficult to
understand how the classical
visual cells of the eye could
be detecting overall brightness
within the
environment.
For vision to work, the visual
cells grab light.
They send that information
off into the brain.
And then essentially
they stop working.
So you have a series
of sharp images.
And it was very difficult to
understand how that image
detecting system could also
get an appreciation of the
overall amount of brightness
and hence time of day.
So there was a big puzzle.
We started using mice in which
the rods and cones had largely
degenerated as a result of
inheritive retinal diseases.
So these mice had lost most
of their rods and cones.
They were visually blind.
And we wanted to see whether
they could still regulate
their body clocks.
And what was absolutely
extraordinary is that these
visually blind mice were able
to regulate their body clock
to the light dark cycle
perfectly normally.
The mouse would get up, run in
its running wheel, and then go
to bed at the same time day
after day after day.
And so we thought, my goodness,
there is something
really interesting
going on here.
There had to be another class
of light-sensitive
cell within the eye.
And the big question, of course,
is, well, if it's not
the rods and cones, then which
of the cells of the inner
retina could it possibly be?
Eventually the light sensitive
molecule was found, and it was
called melanopsin, or OPN4, and
that gene is located on
chromosome 10.
I think knowledge about
this new system
is really very important.
If you think about it, we know
that there's about 40 million
people worldwide who have
no sense of visual
sensitivity at all.
Now understanding that there's
another light sensor within
the eye could hugely improve
the quality of life and the
sense of well-being of
those individuals.
And at the moment,
very little is
discussed about those cells.
So the fact that melanopsin is
turning up in chromosome 10
makes chromosome 10 my
favourite chromosome.